vera bonsoir alors vladimir poutine
s'est exprimé ce soir et il a donc rendu
sa décision
bonsoir pierre la décision est
effectivement prises lors de son adresse
à la nation vladimir poutine a déclaré
qu'il souhaitait que la russie roccon
hesselink dépendance des républiques
populaires de donetsk et de l'ogc ans
c'est maintenant au tour du parlement
russe de se prononcer sur cette question
écoutez il me semble nécessaire de
prendre une décision qui mûrit depuis
longtemps c'est de reconnaître
immédiatement la souveraineté des
républiques populaires de donetsk et de
lougansk
je demande l'assemblée fédérale
de russie de soutenir
cette décision et de signer un accord
d'amitié avec elle ses deux républiques
ces documents seront préparés et signer
très prochainement
et ceux qui tiennent qui ont le pouvoir
à kiev je leur demande de cesser
immédiatement leurs actions de l'état
autrement toute la responsabilité pour
une poursuite de l' effusion de sang il
sera complètement sera complètement de
leur responsabilité
en annonçant la décision d'aujourd'hui
je
le garde une porte garant de soutien de
toute la population du pays lors de son
discours qui a duré une heure où la
dîmière poutine a évoqué également
évoqué la possibilité que le cren se
tente de se doter d'armes nucléaires la
dmr poutine affirme prendre au sérieux
ce qu'elle considère comme un risque
parce que l'ukraine ne tient toujours
des technologies héritées de l'époque
soviétique
à ses yeux ça pourrait faciliter la
récréation d'un arsenal nucléaire de le
crains surtout si l'occident décide de
l'y aider écoutez dans les faits tout se
résume au fait que
l'effondrement de l'économie le crime
est nu e chrétienne va de pair avec
cette guerre civile est en réalité le
cren est géré de l'extérieur c'est pas
seulement
depuis les capitales étrangères mais
directement il ya des représentants de
ces ong de ces de ses services étrangers
qui sont là sur place ils exercent une
influence directe sur le choix du
personnel sur les nominations au pouvoir
sur dans les grandes entreprises
publiques que ce soit naftogaz ukraine
ergo
l'industrie de défense là les postes
ukrainienne les compagnies maritimes
donc il n'ya plus de suture de l'état
aux ordres des autorités occidentales
le
le cren n'a même plus de décisions pour
la nomination des juges aux instances
suprêmes
vladimir poutine également évoqué le
projet par le ton et les états unis des
propositions russes et mise à la fin de
2021 au sujet des garanties de sécurité
de mutuelles s'agissait notamment
d'arrêter l'expansion de l'otan vers
l'est l'adhésion de l'ukraine dans le
temps pour vladimir poutine est une
menace directe pour la sécurité de la
russie merci verhaeghe hoffman pour
toutes ces précisions depuis moscou